the bodies of mostly women children even
babies killed in eastern democratic
republic of congo
the victims were hiding in the forested
area of jugo in aturi province for
several months after fleeing attacks on
their villages
a regional government official blamed
the armed group codeco for carrying out
monday's raid
and 24 hours earlier this happened
bodies strewn among the burning embers
of a village mostly women and children
again the majority of the dozens of
victims
they were killed in an attack by another
rebel group during a raid on the camp
blanket gold mine in italy
a regional monitoring group says
fighting has scarred the regions of
ituri and northern kivu for decades
but it's getting worse
with codeco and the allied democratic
forces armed groups accused of massacres
that's despite a joint operation by
congolese and ugandan soldiers
every time there is uh
attacks
on the the the kodako there is also
represent on the on the civilian and
that that the big issue is that there is
not enough
uh
measure taken to make sure that
civilians are protected
kenya has hosted talks to end the
long-running conflict armed groups are
calling for the release of political
prisoners and amnesty for their fighters
but following the latest attacks many
are concerned that the military approach
isn't working and will lead to more
reprisals in villages like this one
laura berdimani al jazeera
and here's al jazeera's malcolm webb
who's also following the story from
nairobi kenya
sunday's attack more than it was in the
town of mongolia and more than 30
civilians were killed at the time and
health officials there have told us that
since then more people have died from
their injuries in the hospitals bringing
the total
who died in that attack up to 55 and
then on monday night into tuesday
morning in a separate attack just about
25 kilometers from there in a camp
for displaced people around 14 or 15
people were killed that's what we've
been told
by rights groups and conflict of
conflict monitoring group
and civil society activists
in in that area and we've seen video of
the people who were killed in that
attack the bodies
of women and children much of it's too
strong to show
people have been hacked to death with
machetes including children and babies
some of whom
have been beheaded people in these
communities blame an armed group called
cadeco which has been
responsible for a series of atrocities
uh in ituri province in eastern congo
over the last couple of years the armed
group claims to represent the lendu
ethnic group
and often targets people from the hammer
ethnic group but this is the latest
iteration of a conflict that's been
going on for decades
over farmland
and other resources could cadeco now
controls substantial gold
reserves throughout the tory province
across many gold mines and it's been
accused
of collaborating with the army
to sell its gold and to buy guns
and ammunition
which rights groups including amnesty
international who published a report on
it just today
say that
this is just fueling the conflict and
making the whole situation more
dangerous